c'est un nouveau modèle économique à
rebours de la société de marché de la
mondialisation
il est directement inspirée des travaux
de l'économiste écologistes hervé juvin
verve et juin qui figure d'ailleurs
désormais sur la liste rassemblement
national aux européennes
donc il s'agit de consommer local de
dépenser locale voici comment marine le
pen l'exprimer c'était le week-end
dernier lors d'un meeting dans la manche
dans le projet de l'alliance européenne
des nations que nous proposons nous
entendons substitué à la notion du libre
échange c'est à dire à la concurrence
sauvage le juste échange
ce que nous défendons c'est une économie
fondée sur le localisme une économie au
service de l'homme et de la nation au
service des français et des entreprises
françaises pour être complet aller
directement à la source vous propose
d'écouter hervé vu 20 s'était tu auras
la tribune de ce meeting dans la manche
on écoute et puis on en parle le plus
simple ça doit être
et ça doit redevenir d'aller faire ses
courses chez les commerçants de chez soi
de son village le plus simple ça doit
être de pouvoir habiter où l'on a ses
racines où l'on à sa famille où l'on à
ses engagements de vie et c'est la clé
d'une revitalisation de nos territoires
ruraux
cet idéal est aussi partagée par marion
maréchal jack de bilbon oui bien sûr
mais ce mois c'est une idée qui traîne
depuis assez longtemps en fait dans
cette droite là où marine le pen a mis
du temps à s'en emparer puisqu'elle est
très étatiste dans son fonctionnement et
dans son logiciel et donc elles étaient
plutôt sur un logiciel jacobins jusque
là je pense que oui c'est notamment
hervé juvin qui lui avait glissé cette
idée mais elle et elle est assez logique
cette idée en fait quand vous voulez
préserver notamment vos industries ou
vos artisanat en fait c'est un des
moyens de lutter notamment contre le la
globalisation dans ce sens là et contre
l'europe fait c'est de créer notamment
des aoc des aop et c'est donc de donner
un statut à vos productions locales qui
peuvent pas être concurrencé par
d'autres fendues sur sa tenue oui mais
pas assez encore ce que je pense que
c'est ça qu'il faut développer et ça
répond en outre à une des
des demandes je pense déjà les jaunes
qui sont voilà cette désertification des
centres villes des petites des petites
villes ou du périurbain et qui veulent
pouvoir donc avoir des centres villes
qui existe à nouveau donc avec des
commerçants donc avec des productions
locales ce qui mérite notamment de
s'attaquer aux grandes surfaces je pense
est donc à l'importation de produits
venus de trop loin ou de l'étranger en
fait ça mais c'est c'est une vrai qu'il
ya chez notamment de courant identitaire
en fait depuis assez longtemps à droite
je devine pression que ferghana eric pas
tout à fait d'accord à fait d'accord
mais c'est vrai que le terme de
localisme me fait un petit peu rigoler
parce qu'en fait on voit que marine le
pen en fait se débarrasse du mot
protectionnisme et qui aujourd'hui est
un peu mal connoté donc on fait du
protectionnisme ça s'appelle le calice
mais ce n'est ni plus ni moins que le
bon vieux protectionnisme c'est du
protectionnisme et à celles à la même la
même aigreur contre le commerce
international les mêmes mythes sur selon
lesquelles le libre échange de mire l
économie murray à l'emploi alors que
vous voyez on parlait de chômage tout à
l'heure nos voisins suisses qui sont
aussi globalisé que nous non pas le
chômage dans leur vocabulaire du
sélection oranje de leurs productions
locales
la culture est fiancée bloc 1
l'agriculture est sensiblement protégé
comme un peu tous les pays qui ont des
lobbys agricoles puissant mais enfin
c'est quand même une économie qui est
très insérées dans la mondialisation ou
comme la plupart des pays en europe et
ce n'est pas ça qui crée le club le
chômage mais non non c'est simplement
une nouvelle manière on parlait de
manama reconquise et une au pea sur la
droite marine le pen qui tente aussi à
sa manière eu une opé assure malal sur
le moins écolo le localisme d'idées que
pas sommé le calvados est non mais je
serais je pour bien comprendre parce que
quand on écoute hervé juvin
c'est plus que de la
protéger des labels ou des appellations
quand il dit le plus simple ce doit être
de voir adopter moulin ses racines ces
familles se doit est de faire ses
courses chez les commerçants et non en
fait c'est alors déjà un cc du reçu
c'est en fait d'une pensée qui a plus de
50 ans de jacques ellul de charbonneau
des penseurs écologistes qui ont écrit
en fait ces territoires
la façon dont on fait donc c'est une
tartufferie enfin on ne saurait si le fn
est écolo il n'a jamais été au parlement
européen quand il s'agit de voter contre
les travailleurs détachés on s'est
abstenu de voter
on se rappelle aussi de rival agence de
com qui était cité dans les panama
peppers on aime bien aussi les plus
financiers internationaux ça va c'est
une blague
là on est là dans quelque chose non mais
bien sûr je sais bien mais je tiens je
tiens à le dire que ce discours là il
n'a aucun fondement à part essayer de
faire croire que là on va effectivement
entendu gilet jaune et se rend compte
faire entrer dans le territoire
lisez jacques ellul là vous serez
quelque chose n'est pas à la hauteur du
boul l'écologie c'est bien une pensée
révolutionnaire qui est en train de son
heure est en train d'approcher sacrant
du temps y est mes amis aussi là dedans
non non c'est vraiment ellul qui a
théorisé ce set territoriaux cet ancrage
le fait qu'il fallait être logique et
dire que si on veut vivre il faut vivre
ensemble mais au niveau local et que
c'est finalement l'échelon de la
démocratie il est pas forcément au
niveau de l'état il n'est pas forcément
au niveau de la région
enfin il y latine qu'il faut travailler
et à faire un monde où ça vient mais
votre point de vue sur la façon dont
elles utilisent de manière politicienne
j'ai dit c'est une façon de faire du
fric mais parce qu'en france il ya des
mais alors elle y adhère au sur le tard
elle arrive à sortir ça parce que les
européennes arriver parce que derrière
vous aurez un vrai problème en disant on
est contre l'europe n'empêche que
l'europe vous avez des fonds de cohésion
régionaux qui font en sorte que si vous
partez sur ce modèle là on va aider les
régions qui sont les moins favorisés si
vous n'avez pas assez système qui permet
d'aider des régions défavorisées
vous aurez des différences qui était
l'europe d'avant c'est à dire l'europe
de l'est et l'europe de l'ouest en
exemple comment on fait pour accrocher
les wagons
donc il faut aussi penser au delà de
cette façon locale comment on s'organise
au niveau international européen et
international
marc vous avez la parole dans un instant
c'est promis mais d'abord quelques
réactions déjà la réponse alors vous
êtes nombreux sur twitter a pensé être
adepte la question telle qu'on la pose
et s'était ainsi rédigé deux adeptes du
localisme une doctrine qui privilégie ce
qui est local adoptée par le
rassemblement national
trois quarts d'entre vous à nous estime
que oui enfin disent qu'ils en sont
adeptes au rock nous dit enfin un peu de
bon sens dans les propositions
écologistes fin fini l'écologie
mondialistes brownie tôt le localisme
n'est-il pas le bon et il a l'air
d'accord il faut que je retrouve le
localisme n'est-il pas le meilleur moyen
de plomber le pouvoir d'achat il me
semble que si les gens n'achètent pas
local c'est généralement parce que les
produits non locaux sont meilleur marché
antoine complète cette idée bonne mais
reste à savoir si elle peut être vue par
l'europe comme un frein à la concurrence
inscrite dans les traités c'est tout à
fait exact c'est à dire qu'on a un monde
qui a protesté contre le pouvoir d'achat
mais si demain vous resterez des
barrières douanières
pensez vous que le pouvoir d'achat des
consommateurs a vraiment augmenté
maintenant on vous réduisez la
concurrence interne a donc fait
augmenter les prix annoncés
c'est mignon mais de vous à la question
de la vous partez sur le principe qui
est une monnaie unique où il ya une
grande monnaie yen la monnaie locale
aussi le l'iphone c'est un grand débat
croiser navarre ici mais le vrai
problème non bien sûr que si bien sûr ça
a du sens le problème à la monnaie est
comme en bas la monnaie est pourquoi on
n'autorise pas les monnaies locales qui
aurait sauvé la grèce
autrement qu'avec les cures d'austérité
combien la coup de main des monnaies de
quartier ou mais bien changé et c'est là
les stores des dépenses élargissement
parisien a bien sûr c'est vraiment pas
de barrières douanières simplement des
monnaies locales ça permet aussi de
faire coexister mais n'en voulons avec
l'euro échangés à l'échelle locale avec
leurs nouveaux produits étrangers si
vous n'avez qu'une monnaie dans la pièce
que cette faille est barrières
douanières il ya des barrières tout
court je vous propose d'écouter à
nouveau hervé juvin
parce que effectivement son système
implique de fermer les frontières -
écoute non je ne suis pas un nomade
comme les autres je suis de cette terre
et des miens je suis d'un indigène de
france et même de bretagne et je ne veux
pas mourir parquet dans une réserve et
je n'accepte pas les calculs économiques
qui disent finalement c'est rentable de
faire venir un million de migrants
parce qu'ils vont remplacer les enfants
que nous ne savons plus à voir et parce
qu'il coûte moins cher qu'un travailleur
français ou quel travailleur allemand
plutôt d'accord avec lui pas forcément
dans la rhétorique mais oui je pense pas
jusque là dans le dans le dans
l'application de ce système là il
parlait de fermer les frontières pour
les migrants la simple c'était pas
fermer les frontières d'un point de vue
commercial dans le passage que vous avez
passé lui que le front national soit
pour la gestion des frontières de
manière plus bien plus cohérente
vis-à-vis des migrants ça me semble
logique en fait et c'est pas et c'est
pas neuf et on en revient à ce que vous
êtes tout à l'heure sur la question du
chômage en france avec des personnes qui
sont très peu qualifiés qui sont
qualifiés a priori le
le migrant ce qu'on appelle le migrant
enfin bref c'est à dire l'immigration un
peu sauvage ou économique en fait ce
sont pas des gens qualifiés donc si on
raisonne d'un simple point de vue
économique on a tout intérêt envers
venir quoi votre point de vue de
d'économistes sur ce sujet je joue
comment dire je localisme c'est beau
mais comment on va acheter une voiture
locale comment on va acheter une télé
locale
fabriqué par le petit artisan du coin
alors que aussi on sait très bien
qu'aujourd'hui en termes de coûts tant
en termes de capacités de production
ça peut pas être produits localement
donc c'est une belle idée pourquoi pas
effectivement les monnaies locales dont
vous parliez vous n'etes et de la pêche
en ile-de-france qui connaît la pêche
qui utilisent la pêche car ça j'ai vu
voilà j'ai un look so le boussole le sol
violette ces sont des beau très poétique
très beau chez les bobos peut-être
parisiens ou pas mais ça n'a de réalité
que hyper territorialisée locale mais
c'est pas ça qui va sauver le monde a
ajouté m le contrepoids le problème le
problème c'est qu'on a tort ou à raison
on vit dans un monde mondialisé donc on
ne peut pas s'extraire la france n'est
pas un ter qu'on d'uniterre qu'on est
capable de sortir du monde pour faire
des vies différentes alors oui on est vu
à l'étranger comme étant ses
irréductibles gaulois qui font rien
comme les autres certes mais c'est pas
comme ça qu'on va qu'on va construire
l'avenir c'est comme et c'est pas pour
comme ça non plus que je crois un autre
par l'ess et la décroissance s'est passé
écolo en fait ça va ça va aller on va on
veut on ne construit pas l'avenir d'une
nation avec la décroissance ou avec que
de localisme que ce soit une solution
épisodique partiel et les immeubles
habités
si c'est ce à quoi l'a invité mais cela
ne peut pas se substituer à l'autre
voilà et le localisme il a toujours
existé je veux dire les petits vieux
dans les villages ils ont toujours
qu'ils ont fait leurs courses toujours
chez le commerçant du coin ya plus de
commercial a encore sept personnes dans
le centre ville surtout on le sait est
un mode qui fait qu' on a tué selon le
commerçant du village c'est ce modèle
productiviste qui est dit la croissance
il faut aller le chercher avec les dents
les grandes surfaces le bétonnage et non
à profiter parce que
ce n'est celle où tout se sait la croix
regardez et aujourd'hui quand je parlais
tout à l'heure de la révolution écologie
aujourd'hui les gens sont conscients
maintenant que ce modèle là il est
extrêmement dangereux et il est fini
enfin oui nous finira et qu'il faut
trouver effectivement une alternative
quelque chose qui va calmer cette
croissance tueuse parce qu'aujourd'hui
quand vous avez la grande surface qui a
enlevé tous les petits commerces sont en
train de dire mais il faut remettre les
petits commerces et dans les grandes
surfaces vous savez quoi des produits
qui font quatre fois le tour du monde
pour être congelés pour revenir dans
votre assiette et j'en veux plus beauf
et ça les a et vous quand même mais je
vous dis pas le contraire que va
entendre que localement que bien sûr la
main on va pas faire défaut d'internet
quel prix le milieu qu'est le localisme
serait toujours plus écologique il faut
vous avez plein de travaux qui montre
qu'il est papa beaucoup plus
écologiquement rentable de faire pousser
des légumes là où c'est plus ensoleillé
la voulez dire que vous avez pas le pacs
est donc évident avait donc voilà on
voulait mettre autant de régimes en fait
maintenant la seule une partie facile
qu'on parle pas ce n'est pas aujourd'hui
qu'il faut avoir accès c'est open bar et
on va vous fait des fraises des bananes
toute l'année non c'est fini ça l'idée
de la décroissance justement elle est là
pour dire il faut maintenant être
raisonné dans notre croissance
c'est par excellence du coup que vous
proposez c'est le venezuela qui permet
pas du tout mais pas du tout c'est le
fait de réfléchir à un moment sur
l'actuelle micra d'acheter ce que vous
achetez comment comment vous consommez
comment vous voyagez tout ça les gens
sont en train de le mée l'idée de
l'intégrer vous allez vous n'avez plus à
voir tout ça c'est une question de se
priver
voilà une activité locale aussi c'est ça
justement mais j'ai cette chance et ce
sont des gens qui sont dans les endroits
où toute activité économique qui a été
tué en fait donc justement ils ont envie
de evo localisation vous un passage
éclair de la lisa sion alors que vous
opprimez globalisé qui s'en sortent très
bien
je leur ai fait ce genre qu'elle est
très animé c'est le mérite sans doute
mais on va aussi terminé en donnant les
dernières réactions nos internautes ce
discours est plutôt et topiques nous dit
monsieur babineau car l'union européenne
ne permet pas de faire du localisme à
grande échelle et brownie ctos les
circuits courts sont une bonne chose
mais effectivement ça ne peut pas
concerner l'ensemble de la production on
passe à notre dernier sujet alors il est